[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes lundi soir et c'est
donc audition publique une heure de
politique en direct avec lcp assemblée
nationale public sénat et le figaro live
une heure pour faire le point sur toute
l'actualité politique du moment et quand
on parle de des dossiers actuellement
c'est celui des retraites
évidemment dont nous allons parler avec
notre invité ce soir gilles legendre
bonsoir bonsoir député de paris et
président du groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée nationale plus de
300 députés c'est un groupe très
important
pas toujours facile à gérer on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est jean paul delevoye le
haut-commissaire aux retraites qui a
démissionné après toutes les affaires
qui lui étaient imputés sur des noms
déclaration d'intérêts notamment ou de
situation vous avez déjà que vous étiez
triste que vous respectiez sa décision
est-ce que vous avez été surpris
pas vraiment parce que nous étions en
contact depuis longtemps avec jean paul
ii voit depuis plusieurs jours la
tristesse c'est la tristesse de l'ami je
sais que c'est très difficile à admettre
pour l'opinion peut-être pour la presse
pour les français qu'on puisse mêler ces
considérations là donc je les laisse de
côté jean-paul sait parfaitement ce que
nous en pensons
les députés entretiennent avec lui un
lien très étroit très fraternel parfois
filiale mettons ça à part maintenant ce
qui compte c'est le fait qu' il a pris
une décision d'homme politique
responsable qui n'a qu'une finalité que
la réforme à laquelle il a consacré
toute son énergie et son talent depuis
deux ans puissent voir le shoegaze vous
l'a dit également oui et et d'une
certaine manière et n'a pris cette
décision qu'en fonction de ce critère là
sans du tour reconnaître que vous allez
vous voulez dire que s'il n'avait pas
démissionné sa réforme était hypothéquée
c'est ce qu'il dit donc moi je l'entends
et je respecte cette décision et je
respecte cette explication vous dites
que vous n'avez pas été surpris nous on
a été surpris parce que pendant 48
heures ce week-end encore c'était à tous
les niveaux les ministres les députés
les porte parole dans marche c'était il
est de bonne foi il n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils démissionnent et puis patatras on
apprend qu'il démissionne il est bonne
foi jean paul delevoye est parfait
mende bonne foi il a commis des erreurs
des négligences il a commencé à les
réparer je dis que c'était normal que ce
soit lui qui prennent cette décision ça
n'était pas à nous de la prendre pour
lier pas eu de pressions de la part du
gouvernement pour qu'il prenne ses
décisions et moi je ne suis pas dans les
relations avec le gouvernement mais elle
et la certitude que cette décision il
l'a prise
comme toujours dans sa vie politique en
homme libre
alors les questions d'énergie legendre
c'est maintenant et qu'elle suit on va
accueillir pour ça brigitte boucher de
lcp assemblée nationale et à mme tran
huy de public sénat
[Musique]
soit vous vite bonsoir tab oui alors
justement la suite si la réforme des
retraites et pour porter cette réforme
parce qu'il faut un successeur à jean
paul delevoye est ce qu'il faut à
nouveau un haut-commissaire aux
retraites pour vous alors ça n'est pas
la question qui s'il le faut c'est qu'il
y aura l'elysée a été extrêmement clair
c'est d'ailleurs sa compétence n'est pas
celle du président de groupe ni de dire
s'il faut remplacer jean paul delevoye
ni par qui mais la présidence de la
république va probablement procéder au
remplacement de jean paul delevoye sur
une proposition qui selon la
constitution doit être lui être faite
par le premier le profil devrait avoir
le successeur de jean paul delevoye
certainement connaître déjà bien ce
dossier qui est d'une très grande
technicité et la forme d'antan en
mettant pas en une immense ambition de
progresser dans vos rangs des députés
franchement nous ne sommes pas là pour
faire le casting du gouvernement c'est
le premier ministre et le président de
la république qui doivent prendre leur
décision
s'il me demande mon avis évidemment je
leur donnerai tout droit des noms de
votre avis quand même parce qu'il ya un
nom qui circulera pas brouiller premier
ministre et président de la république à
la mairie circulons groupe alors ils ont
peut-être envie de vous entendre là
dessus c'est donc gérald darmanin est ce
que pour vous groupe
non bien sûr ce nom là alors j'ai encore
eu à donner mon avis il ne s'agit pas de
me prendre un mais meilleur élément est
ce qu'il a un bon profil pour vous
est-ce qui connais suffisamment le
dossier ce qui pourrait le défendre à
l'évidence oui il connaît le dossier il
le défend bien il le défend sous son
angle le plus politique est patent sous
son angle budgétaire et donc c'est ce
qui compte le plus ah je suis absolument
convaincu et c'est d'ailleurs un défi
pour chacun d'entre nous dans notre
majorité que nous ne convaincrons nous
ne convaincrons pardon les français de
la pertinence de cette réforme ce qu'il
commence à comprendre et de l'intérêt de
cette réforme
quand nous situant sur le terrain
politique c'est à dire en montrant très
clairement les progrès magistraux que
cette réforme va permettre d'opérer en
termes de justice sociale et de
protection des
français les plus fragiles y en a un qui
a largement fait ce travail depuis un
certain nombre de jours c'est edouard
philippe le premier ministre est ce que
vous seriez favorables à l'hypothèse que
lui même puisse défendre ce texte dans
l'hémicycle ce serait possible c'est que
le premier ministre cela me paraît très
baroque mais après tout il en a
parfaitement le droit
constitutionnellement il ya déjà eu dans
le passé des premiers ministres qui
cumulait leurs fonctions de premier
ministre et un maroquin ministériel
particules mais parce que le premier
ministre toute façon le porte déjà ce
projet en tant que chef du gouvernement
qui reçoit les syndicats cette semaine
ou qui va recevoir les attendait non
mais attendez défaut qui mieux que se
défendre au banc vous le savez très bien
vos journalistes de lcp vous savez très
bien que ce sont des jours et des nuits
au banc c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
c'est toujours les ministres qui le font
le premier à d'autres responsabilités
aux mamans on passe dans la lecture du
texte maintenant
encore une fois ça n'est pas à moi de
décider cette affaire là tout est ouvert
mais brigitte alors demain il ya une
grosse manifestation qui est annoncé
s'il ya plus de monde que le 5 décembre
précédentes grosses journées de
manifestation les 150000 personnes si
mam demain sur l'interface le million de
personnes dans la rue ça change quoi
selon vous alors je vais vous dire
quelque chose
voyez de boucher je suis convaincu qu'il
y aura beaucoup de monde je suis
incapable de dire combien je suis même
pas certain de pouvoir dire qu'on aura
plus mais c'est fort probable qu'il y en
aura plus pour une raison très simple
c'est que maintenant tous les syndicats
se sont unis pour cette manifestation
même s'ils défendent des causes
radicalement différente comme vous le
savez vous êtes vous êtes fatalisme non
je suis pas fataliste je suis
respectueux le droit de manifestation
est un droit constitutionnel et notre
responsabilité pouvoirs publics en
général et notamment le ministère de
l'intérieur et les forces de l'ordre à
qui je souhaite rendre hommage dès
aujourd'hui notre responsabilité et que
ce droit de manifestation puisse
s'exercer
finalement parce que le rapport de force
ne sera plus le même le rapport de force
ne tiendra pas au nombre
personne dans la rue incroyable non je
n'y crois pas ces deux choses déconnecté
ce que nous savons et ça n'est pas les
manifestations qu'ils nous le disent
c'est que nous devons négocier en toute
circonstance qu'il y en ait quatre cent
mille qu'il y en ait eu 800 milles qu'il
y en ait un million et demi
nous devons négocier et nous voulons
négocier pour une raison très simple
nous voulons aller au bout de cette
nouvelle fois revenir damian pas que les
personnes dans la rue il ya aussi les
sondages qui montrent que les français
aient un sondage ifop ce week end que
54% des français continuent à soutenir
le mouvement
ça montre aussi que vous n'avez pas
réussi à convaincre les français vous
savez alors que nous n'avions pas encore
réussi à convaincre tous les français
c'est une vérité
le projet majorité d'entre dame le
projet a été définie de façon précise
pour la première fois mercredi dernier
c'est un projet révolutionnaire de
refondation entiers de notre régime de
retraite
hélas les dires mêmes de la conception
même que nous nous faisons de la
protection sociale dans notre pays
penser qu'en huit jours nous ayons pu
ramener toute l'opinion derrière nous
c'est un leurre ctv siffle v6 avez vous
parlé de sondages madame parce que
franchement verte est un projet de
justice sociale normalement cela devrait
plutôt convaincre d'y aller parce que il
est compliqué il est technique
beaucoup de gens peuvent se poser encore
des questions qui n'ont pas encore
toutes les réponses
mais vous savez vous parlez de single oh
mais je suis prêt à prendre tous les
reproches bruits de bouche et surtout
dans votre voix mais franchement si on
parle des sondages
qu'est ce que je vois aussi c'est que la
popularité du président legarda le
président de la république et du premier
ministre augmente
vous savez les sondages je n'en tire
aucune fierté quand ils sont bons je
n'en tire aucune
aucun trouble quand ils sont moins bons
ce que je sais et ce à quoi notre
majorité toute entière et notamment les
députés de mon groupe sont entièrement
mobilisés
nous devons convaincre les français et
les entends le sentiment vous jouez un
peu l'opinion contre la re comparé
exemple vous demander une trêve de noël
est ce que ce n'est pas une façon de
mettre un peu les français de votre
coach observe que je ne sus nous ne
sommes pas les seuls
en d un certain nombre de syndicats
considèrent qu'il serait normal les
français vous avez ne comprendrait pas
qu'on ne respecte pas cette trêve qui
est multi séculaire auquel tous les
français sont attachés quels que soient
leur religion leur croyance leur niveau
social leur métier c'est sacré cette
période là il faut la respecter et pour
la respecter nous devons très clairement
engagée très vite les discussions avec
les syndicats
je veux j'ai appris en venant vous voir
que les dates étaient fixés que l'on
craignait que le voilà que le premier
ministre avait fixé deux séries de
rencontres une le mercredi une le jeudi
est donc ça c'est très bien on parlera
peut-être du rôle que le groupe entend
jouer un rôle dans cette tendance années
dans cette discussion
et puis et ça ça nous laisse encore du
temps rien ne sera conclu dans la
semaine mais en face il déjà le laisse
keith d'une confiance s'instaure pas ce
que je vais vous dire dans cette affaire
on peut aller à l'infini dans les
détails techniques et ça le sujet est
tellement complexe qu'on peut s'y noyer
le vrai que la trêve est le vrai sujet
brive et de boucher c'est de restaurer
la confiance et je fais totalement
confiance au premier ministre au
gouvernement est aussi aux partenaires
sociaux qui sont pour cette réforme
même s'ils ont des points de désaccord
très fort sur certains sujets qui les
amène à manifester demain je fais
confiance aux deux parties pour qu ils
portent plus haut l'intérêt du pays
sans renier rien de leurs convictions
oui de leurs objectifs et les nôtres
sont très claires très clair mais en
mettant au dessus
l'intérêt général qui est que l'on
retrouve les transports pendant la
période je vais vous poser une question
si les négociations durent pendant
presque jusqu'à noël
comment voulez vous que ça redémarre
mais j'appelle ça une trêve par
définition une grève n'est pas une
conclusion définitive je vous dis le but
est de restaurer la confiance le but
n'est pas de faire aboutir en 48 heures
des négociations sur des sujets
compliqués je pense notamment l'âge
déquilibre à la régulation financière
que pense à la pénibilité
je pense aux carrières longues je pense
au mit
imam contributif vous savez ce fameux
mille euros en dessous duquel il n'y
aura plus aucune pension dans le futur
système d'amis dont tu veux y'a de quoi
un grand syndicaliste que vous n'avez
pas connu parce que vous êtes trop jeune
disait il ya du grain à moudre
il ya des choses à moudre en effet dans
cette négociation s'est d'ailleurs il
faut absolument absolument les mettre au
centre de l'adra bergeron je leur dis
vous dis oui il ya beaucoup de grain à
moudre et beaucoup d'esprits qui sont
eux calme aujourd'hui est ce qu'en tant
que présente deux groupes
vous seriez prêt est ce qu'on retarde la
discussion à l'assemblée justement pour
calmer les esprits pour retrouver un peu
un vrai climat de serena je n'y suis pas
favorable
maintenant comme vous le savez pas ce
que vous êtes des finalistes du monde
parlementaire ce n'est pas le groupe
parlementaire ni son président qui a la
maîtrise de l'ordre du jour à leur âge
je suis très favorable à ce qu'on vote
cette loi rapidement avant les
municipales entre la lecture je souhaite
que nous l'avions avant les municipales
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale
maintenant je sais que nous avons encore
des discussions approfondies à avoir
mais mais tout est compliqué tout est
compliqué et c'est pas très grave que ça
soit compliqué vous savez encore une
fois la question clé c'est la confiance
et si je peux me permettre francis
letellier il y a dans cette loi futur
une chose dont on parle peu qu'ils en
appellent ça sous son terme barbare de
la gouvernance
je vais le dire de façon plus simple
c'est la manière dont sera pilotée gérer
le futur régime de retraite et cette
gouvernance elle fait appel massivement
aux partenaires sociaux jusqu'à que mai
aux partenaires sociaux
justement si on veut qu'elle fonctionne
il faut que nous soyons capables de
restaurer dans notre pays une confiance
dans ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
sociale qui est le lien entre les
organisations syndicales et les pouvoirs
publics
résistons nous de cette magnifique
réforme pour jeter les fondements g
d'une démocratie sociale plus mature
plus responsable c'est la plus proche
délai que vous dites il faut restaurer
la confiance la cfdt mais un préalable
elle demande le retrait de cet âge pivot
qui est fixé à 64 ans est ce que vous
seriez prêt à accepter cela vous qui
avez d'ailleurs tendu la main à laurent
berger pour qu'ils viennent à
l'assemblée
alors il faut être très précis il parle
d'un pivot d'arte équilibre là
d'équilibré est un thème mieux approprié
puisque c'est un terme statistiques
c'est l'âge qui équilibre le régiment
pourra points d'accord à un moment donné
de la population si non mais ça c'est
pas qu'on veuille nous qu'on veuille pas
c'est un fait mais comme vous allez
rétablir ce qui est compliqué c'est
l'usagé qu'on en fait qui est le bonus
et le malus qui permet de garantir
l'équilibré effectifs financiers nous
nous considérons le gouvernement la
majorité qu' il n'y a pas de réforme
sérieuse des retraites qui ne sécurise
l'équilibré financier du régime 75 m eur
de 26 ans de l'âge non les ménages dès
qu'il est mon ne retire pas c'est un
fait brésil pour servir ensuite
non parce qu'ensuite ce que conteste la
cbt si les instruments qu'on met en
place pour que cette algue équilibre
soit respectée les écolos par exemple
donc et là dessus le premier ministre a
été extrêmement clairs nous pouvons
négocier tous les scénarios possibles
qui permettent d'atteindre l'accès du
rythme et celle des finances
il faut un région là ceux qui ne veulent
pas du bonus malus voilà voilà
oui mais ils ne disent plus aussi
fermement qu'avant qu'ils sont opposés à
examiner la question de l'équilibré
financier du régime
et si je vais bien et si je vais plus
loin oui mais c'est très important
nous ne sortirons gagnants les uns et
les autres de cette négociation que si
nous sortons du seul sujet binaire
malus-bonus pupa malus bonus on ne peut
pas sortir d'une zone comme ça quand on
se concentre de façon obsessionnelle sur
un seul sujet nous devons mettre sur la
table un paquet de ce message
j'ai mais voilà d'amener au moins la
cfdt elle a rejoint la mobilisation à
l'appel à manifester demain ça a créé
des inquiétudes au sein de votre groupe
lesquels des inquiétudes n'ont pas
simplement au sein de notre groupe une
forte déception
vous savez il y aurait quelque chose de
paradoxal à ce que cette réforme qui à
l'approbation pour 90 95 % de ce compte
de son contenu de trois syndicats
essentielles qui sont la cfdt l'unsa et
la cftc trébuche que cette réforme
trébuche parce que précisément on
n'arrive pas à s'entendre sur les 5 à
10% restants pour 126 et aurons nous
devons donc nous devons nous entendre
sur ce qui fait encore des désaccords
nous car c'est le pur sang bulger une
chose c'est une évaluation non
scientifique mais alors c'est dit c'est
pour dire très clairement non mais
attendez on part sérieusement suisse
avoue francis letellier je suis sérieux
quand un syndicats comme la cfdt dit
cette réforme nous emportons la
philosophie les principes les objectifs
depuis plus longtemps que vous femmes et
hommes de la macro ni on doit se dire
c'est quand même formidable on doit
avoir cette alliée avec nous et donc on
a pas on ne doit pas on l'a en très
grande partie on l'a pas en totalité
nous devons trouver le terrain qui
permet de l'avoir avec nous et c'est la
même chose car je ne fais pas de
traitement particulier pour la cfdt avec
l'unsa et la cfdt
les autres syndicats nous ne
demanderions pas mieux qu'ils viennent
avec nous mais ils nous ont dit dès le
départ qu'il ne voulait rien c'est très
fort on voit bien les négociations il
n'y en aura mercredi jeudi avec le
premier ministre avec les syndicats
notamment la cfdt les syndicats
réformistes
finalement quelle marge de manoeuvre et
restera au groupe la république en
marche pour négocier est ce que vous
aurez la place pour quelques amendements
ou est-ce que tout sera ficelé d'avant
alors ne parlons pas encore des
amendements même dans la phase actuelle
le groupe que je préside entend jouer
tout son rôle de parlementaire un
traitement concrètement ça veut dire
plusieurs choses
première chose nous pouvons parler à
tout le monde et écouter tout le monde
et j'ai pris en fin de semaine dernière
l'initiative d'inviter les trois
syndicats réformistes à venir discuter
avec une délégation du groupe
ça aura lieu une fois corps ont repris
les discussions entre le premier
ministre et les organisations indices
d'accord ils ont donné d'accord de
principe c'est dans ces domaines a
priori ça va au moins commencer cette
semaine d'accord la deuxième chose il ne
faut pas se tromper de nom deuxième
chose il ne faut pas se tromper il ne
peut y avoir deux négociations
parallèles
nous nous discutons avec l'exécutif
c'est auprès de l'exécutif que nous
pouvons peser vers telle ou telle option
et nous entendons jouer ce rôle
pleinement et l'exécutif est
parfaitement ouvert à ce que nous
jouions ce rôle auprès de lui en nous
disant en lui disant ce que la majorité
souhaite et qu'on discute
en revanche il n'y a pas de négociations
parallèles et il ya un seul négociateur
c'est le premier ministre mais le groupe
est là pour aider à ce que le dialogue
s'installe à ce que l'aménagement est
bien venu pour apporter des aménagements
et pour discuter en permanence avec eux
dans l'hémicycle également après
toujours le droit d'amendement brigitte
boucher et et du sionisme a écouté plus
l'accord sera solide - les députés
auront envie de le déstabiliser par tel
ou tel amendement
maintenant vous savez très bien qu'il ya
des amendements qui porte sur des choses
très importantes et la bande moi qui
porte sur des faits moins important ce
qui est certain pour une bouchée et je
le dis solennellement le groupe que je
préside a été associé à cette réforme
grâce à jean paul delevoye depuis deux
ans comme à aucun autre projet
gouvernemental depuis deux ans et demi
et nous jouerons notre rôle à fond de
gouttes en bout y compris dans la
période actuelle où la prix
rites et c'est la reprise bien
discussions et des négociations va
revenir sur les retraites hauteur avec
les parlementaires qui vont nous
rejoindre mais tu as une question
d'actualité autres à vous poser
effectivement jean luc mélenchon s'en
est pris au crif en commentant la
situation politique britannique
il a parlé je le cite des génuflexions
devant les oukases arrogant des
communautaristes du crif
que pensez vous de ces propos beaucoup
de mal mais je n'en dirai pas plus
pourquoi pourquoi toute sortie phrase
saillie qui excite des passions dont on
sait qu'elle ne demande qu'à s'enflammer
dans le pays est indigne d'un
responsable politique
nous devons avoir la mission exactement
inverse rassemblé apaisé réunir que
temps de faire jean luc mélenchon avec
ses propos ça je j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour jean luc mélenchon qui est un grand
responsable politique bien plus
expérimentés que je le suis mais s'il ya
une chose dont je suis bien incapable
c'est de lire dans ses pensées bien
brigitte une petite question sur le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée il ya la
députée sabine tilaï qui refuse de céder
son poste à pierre alexandre anglade qui
a remporté l'élection à la présidence de
la commission des affaires européennes
élection interne à la candy à la
désignation des n'a pas été élu par la
commission des affaires européennes il a
essayé dans notre groupe bien sûr donc
c'est lui maintenant il ya le post elle
renonce non c'est lui qui devrait la mer
voilà pourquoi vous n'arrivez pas à
faire respecter ce règlement que vous
avez vous même fixé parce que le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale fixe
que pour la commission des affaires
européennes
le mandat s'exercent pour cinq ans et le
seul moyen qu'il y aurait deux ans et
qu'elle démissionne ce qu'elle refuse de
faire et vous ne pouvez pas la pousser
sa poussée je peux vous dire que je le
fais mais je dois le reconnaître avec
une efficacité qui comme vous le
constatez laisse beaucoup à désirer le
président du groupe quand même ah oui
mais vous savez un groupe parlementaire
ça n'est pas une armée d'accord mais là
non ça n'est pas à côté même une
rédaction est un monument discipline
doit alors là c'est bon une autre
question si que voulez-vous poesy tram à
propos d
des parlementaires de chez vous qui sont
parfois prises à partie oui
effectivement un des députés un
maquereau nice sont menacés jusque chez
eux
aujourd'hui avec la réforme des
retraites d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la
première fois il y avait eu les liégeois
n'ont apparemment est ce que vous
demandez des mesures de protection pour
ces députés comment est ce que vous vous
saisissiez de ce problème
égoutter dieu soit loué la situation
actuelle n'a plus rien à voir avec celle
que nous avons connue pendant de longs
mois au moment de la crise des gilet
jaune après et aussi avec un deuxième
accès au moment du vote du sénat
je ne dis pas ça pour susciter les
initiatives et exciter les imaginations
d'une des boîtes et oui c'est un c'est
un vrai scandale quand en plus on vient
dans les lieux privés déjà dégradé une
permanence c'est inadmissible mais alors
quand en plus on va menacer les éléments
de famille d'un élu de la d'un ou d'une
élue de la république
en l'espèce une élue c'est est ce qu'il
faut c'est des syndicats rappellent à
l'ordre leurs troupes
écoutez je pense qu'ils le font je leur
fais confiance pour le faire une des
grandes des grands avantages des
syndicats par rapport au mouvement que
nous avons connu l'année dernière c'est
que c'est un petit peu mieux organisées
maintenant je ne veux pas non plus faire
de cet incident tout à fait
répréhensible et condamnable un immense
événement mais bon c'est une question
peut-être dans vos rangs qui ont fait
monter la pression qu'ils ont fait at il
a collé aux pleurs ni chars je veux bien
ne pas monter au rideau à chaque
incident mais alors vous n'allez pas me
demander en plus de faire une sorte
d'autocritique comme si nous étions
responsables des avanies qui nous arrive
non ça n'irait pas jusque là mais les
pleurnichards les irresponsables ce
qu'il fallait
c'est s'était approprié moi je n'ai pas
prononcé ces mots là je ne me sens pas
concerné par ces questions vous sentez
pas solidaire de richard ferrand ou d
isabey d'or ah si ces deux là
au contraire je suis très bas écoutez
c'est qu'ils avaient probablement des
bonnes raisons pour les prononcer ah bon
merci brigitte merci tab et à l'année
prochaine bien cher avec plaisir
audition publique c'est aussi le lieu où
les parlementaires qui sont au coeur des
débats viennent vous interpeller on va
les accueillir dans un instant bonsoir
roger karoutchi sénateur les
républicains de paris est bon ce soir au
sénat les hauts-de-seine pardon pardon
pardon cinq villes de france 2 d'un bloc
et luc carvounas député ps du
val-de-marne
bon c'est bien en ile de france on va
commencer à parler des retraites et
roger karoutchi vous interpeller sur
apprennent de cohérence dit-il de
cohérence et de coups parce que cette
réforme des retraites
elle avait été initiée sur le thème le
système n'est pas durable et on nous a
dit la retraite à points ou sur le
principe pourquoi pas sauf qu'après on
est rentré dans le détail
et puis on se rend compte que pour les
enseignants ça tient pas on se rend
compte que on ne pourra pas arriver à un
seul régime universel est en réalité
quel est le coût à terme de cette
réforme des retraites si elle se fait
c'est d'un côté d'un coût colossal des
gens parlent de 10 milliards nécessaires
pour les enseignants sur les cinq à dix
ans qui viennent
mais on n'a pas encore chiffré pour les
infirmiers on n'a pas encore chiffré
pour un certain nombre de professions ce
qui veut dire qu'en dehors de
l'équilibré des retraites pour l'état ça
va être un coût colossal dans les dix
années qui viennent et quant au rêve du
régime universel même si théoriquement
c'est très beau d'ores et déjà je
castanheira dit pas de régime universel
pour les policiers régime dérogatoire
monsieur le doyen dit naturellement pour
les militaires d'autres vont venir aussi
il y aura donc plusieurs régimes de
toute manière alors est-ce qu'il faut
tout sacrifié sur le thème du régime
universel ou est-ce qu'il faut trouver
des accommodements pour aller vers une
convergence sans forcément être sur une
théorie unique voilà alors il ya
plusieurs questions dans votre propos
premièrement il y aura un
régime universel unique pour tout le
monde à points ce qui va prendre du
temps et qui exige un traitement
différencié
c'est la convergence des 42 régime vers
le régime unique parce qu'en effet le
professeur le policier
l'infirmière le salarié du privé ça
n'est pas pareil et donc si nous voulons
aller vers ce régime universel unique
nous devons admettre qu'il y à des
transitions mais elles vont prendre du
temps et des transitions elle joue sur
deux variables
le calendrier qui ne sera pas forcément
le même pour tout le monde et les
mesures d'accompagnement qui doivent
précisément faire en sorte qu'avec le
temps au fur à mesure que les
générations concernées prendront leur
retraite personne ne soit lésé
premiers éléments de réponse deuxième
élément de réponse le coût ni nous
sommes à engager parce que le futur
régime de retraite ne pèse pas plus dans
la régie dans la richesse nationale
qu'il ne pèse aujourd'hui c'est à dire 1
14%
ce qui ne signifie en aucun cas que nous
allons brider les pensions parce que
dieu soit loué la richesse nationale
augmentant le 14 % permet d'augmenter
périodiquement les ressources dévolues
aux retraites
troisième chose le cas des enseignants
certes nous nous sommes engagés et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale est en
train de discuter avec les syndicats
de quelle manière va se dérouler cet
engagement nous nous sommes engagés à
une revalorisation des rémunérations qui
a comme finalité comme finalité de faire
en sorte que au moment où les
enseignants dans le nouveau régime
prendront leur retraite ils ne soient
pas défavorisé par rapport à ce qu'était
le régime antérieur
mais les revalorisations de rémunération
roger karoutchi ne figureront pas dans
le droit des retraites
ce sont des rémunérations c'est sur des
revalorisations de rémunération mais
roger karoutchi mais est-ce finalement
dans le bois des reprographie est ce
qu'une fois dans votre
si vous n'avez pas dit le salaire des
professeurs dans notre pays d'un
scandale la belge était professeur à
l'om est-ce que je suis d'accord donc
mais dont le nom mais si c'est très
clair non parce que j'ai pas les
catégories très clairement que c'est
parce que nous devons en garantir les
retraites des enseignants que nous
sommes obligés de revaloriser leur
rémunération
mais c'est très bien ainsi bien parce
que ça met fin à un scandale social
oui que vous avez dénoncé que j'ai
dénoncée et qu'à mon avis autour de
cette base nous avons mais qui n'est pas
financé non nous le financerons mais
comme nous le financerons presque qui
sont évoqués sont des sommes est allé
sur une très longue période plus que
l'on rejoint ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
la transition se fait dans le temps et
avec des mesures d'accompagnement roger
karoutchi parler de 10 milliards sur
cinq ans c'est un chiffre qui circule
pas fort 50 sur plus longtemps je le
fais déjà sur plus de 10 ans sur cette
suite
eh bien écoutez si c'est pour mettre fin
à un scandale absolu à savoir que les
professeurs ne sont pas exempts d accord
débarrassé de m'allonger vous êtes
d'accord
on le trouvera alors bas ça vient alors
lui car vous ne vous en dirais que le
déficit ne cesse de baisser dans notre
pays depuis que nous avons fait la jada
née luc carvounas lors d'une question
justement toujours sur les rails et des
finances moi je suis entendu dire gilles
legendre que les choses sont claires
non elles sont pas clients elles sont
pas claires parce que déjà ils n'ont pas
été claires par les voies nombreuses
souvent dissonante au niveau du
gouvernement y compris dans les membres
de la majorité à l'assemblée nationale
que nos compatriotes à maman en temps
d'une génération qui est celle de 1963
et puis ensuite on passe à 1975 mais ça
sera en 1985 pour les régimes spéciaux
mais comme il ya la chp et vous à 64 ans
revit en génération 2160 et le
compatriote milliard quand vous disiez
tout à l'heure tu aura beaucoup de monde
demain
pourquoi y aura beaucoup de monde demain
parce que les gens ils sont dans un
climat anxiogène parce qu'ils ont
compris que chose de très simple on va
leur demander de travailler plus et
gagner moins
apparemment on air a calculé sur
l'ensemble d'une carrière
et moi je vais vous dire vous est pris
dans le mal
you corner qu'il ya un nom lorsque bercy
chercher comment boucler le budget de
l'état en allant faire les poches des
usagers sur la trajectoire de la taxe
carbone et on est la taxe est censée on
a vu comment vous avez reculé
c'était quelque chose de plusieurs
milliards sur le quinquennat quand vous
avez fait des choix politiques qui sont
pas les miens c'est la démocratie vous
avez plein majorité à l'assemblée
mais quand vous avez fait le choix
d'inscrire lui six dans le projet de loi
de finances qu'on avait fait le choix d
exonérer la taxe d'habitation 30
milliards quand vous faites le choix de
faire l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes
en forme 10 filles 5 milliards il ya un
problème de partage des richesses et à
ce moment là vous avez désormais décider
pas vous pardon puisque ce ne sont plus
les politiques qui font société dans ce
pays
mais les hauts fonctionnaires 13e rang
de berne
c'est la malheureuse région et
aujourd'hui vous refaites le mât la même
erreur qui a un nom qui a provoqué la
crise des gilet jaune en allons faire la
paix poches des usagers dans mon pays
plus d'essence et là vous allez faire la
poche des salariés parce que vous
n'arrivez pas à boucler le budget de
l'état répond nationale alors on parle
pas du jeu d'état on est en train de
parler d'une réforme des retraites alors
pierre lavoie je vois bien le rem crise
je vois bien ce n'est pas on n'est pas
dans un film de michel ocelot
j'aimerais bien je vois bien votre rêve
luc carvounas et c'était d'ailleurs un
rébus de nous inquiéter
ç'a sûrement ça c'est pas un vrai c'est
l'autre jour c'était autres noix et
c'est la décision des français essayons
de l'être si vous toutefois vous me
laissez vous répondre je vois bien votre
rêve
vous auriez rêvé que la réforme des
retraites provoque le même type de
révolte que l'augmentation des deux
l'adolescence l'année dernière ça ne
s'est pas produit précisément parce que
les français savent parfaitement que la
réforme que nous portons est d'abord la
réforme sur laquelle nous nous sommes
engagés au moment où nous avons nous
sommes soumis à leurs souffrances
c'était extrêmement clair nous l'avions
dit et ils savent très bien que derrière
cette réforme il ya un objectif d'équité
et de justice sociale que vous feignez
de nier mais qui est réel vous savez
parfaitement que le régime à points
plus toutes les mesures que nous les
avons a rajouté le minimum de retraite
garanti regardez les mesures pour les
femmes les femmes qui ont des enfants j
pour les carrières a fait part s'y
attendait si ça marchera et ça fera de
la redistribution au profit des 40% les
français les plus modestes ils le savent
d'où vient aujourd'hui le fait qu'il ya
des gens dans la rue le fait c'est
essentiellement jeu c'était non ben déjà
fini bien sûr on est là pour sa fille
mais c'est je finis c'est
essentiellement et vous le savez
parfaitement ce et les régimes spéciaux
cercle nous mettons fin aux régimes
spéciaux
nous les mettons nous mettons fin avec
les aménagements le temps qu'il faut
pour respecter les personnes aujourd'hui
en mai difficile mais mais mais reste
mais les autres français qui ne sont pas
dans les régimes spéciaux ils ne sont
pas en grève
les autres français qui ne sont pas dans
le régime spéciaux ils ne sont pas dans
la rue
il nous disait il attend de notre part
des explications nous sommes là pour les
donner aux qu'est ce qu'ils savent faire
des choix d'école simple qu'est l'école
st j'étais maire de la commune je suis
né alfort et un fonctionnaire
territorial qui rentre à 20 ans
catégorie c'est le plus bel l'échelle à
1200 euros net par mois
donc les primes 0,1 dans le calcul qui
progresse tout au long de sa vie qui
passe les concours internes qui devient
catégorie b catégorie a et qui devient
même le directeur général des services
d'une commune on va lui expliquer vous
allez m'expliquer comprenons le calcul
sur l'ensemble de sa vie les 42 ans il
va gagner une pension identique que si
on avait fait sur les six derniers mois
la veste mais mejia il ya un miracle
mathématique que je ne souffre que vous
des dires traduit si je peux me
permettre le carbonate le fait que vous
n'êtes pas encore passés dans la logique
à point la logique à points n'est pas
celle là
vous le savez parfaitement quand on
cotise non c'est pas des miracles c'est
pas des miracles
écoutez pourquoi la cfdt serait
favorable à la retraite par points si
comme vous le dites
l institution sénégalais gerbe et il
faisait sur le cas mais bien le
fonctionnaire comme le salarié comme
l'infirmière achètent des points au fur
et à mesure de sa carrière et quand ils
liquident sa sa retraite il transforme
ces points en pension plus il a eu trois
lectrices mais voyait ce qu'il va voir
la même pension qu'aujourd'hui oui ça
passera demain nous sommes engagés à
l'esa nous nous sommes engagés à ça et
le moyen et des moyens qu'on met tout en
oeuvre pour que vous êtes engagements
soient tenus
c'est précisément ce que je répondais
tout à l'heure à roger karoutchi
nous avons toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement et le calendrier
l'étalement dans le temps
je voulais juste répondre à 0,10 n'est
pas répandue à luc carvounas sur la
question du 1963 de 1975 vous essayé de
brouiller les pistes
vous savez très bien c'était va cesser
de nous sous louis et bien entre 63 1963
qui était l'idée de jean paul delevoye
en juillet et 1975 qui a été annoncé par
le premier ministre il ya une chose
extrêmement importante que vous feignez
d'oublier là aussi et qui s'appelle la
concertation précisément cette saison
c'est soit ça 1975 c'est d'une des
choses que nous réclamaient les
syndicats et que le gouvernement a
décidé aujourd'hui une section tous les
débats pourraient avoir lieu d'abord au
parlement et points mais on va pas y
revenir moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui
la réforme n'est pas financée et qu'elle
n'est pas finançable
en l'état c'est fort 11e éléments que
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez mais
j'ai dit mon opinion deuxième élément je
vous dis simplement que quand vous le
dit tout va converger ça n'est pas vrai
les policiers et militaires conserveront
le régime dérogatoire jusqu'à la fin des
temps parce que c'est comme ça et qu'il
n'accepterait pas autrement et ils ont
raison
donc tu auras d'autres régimes
particuliers troisième élément ce débat
est fou deux ans de consultations
on attendait les mesures pour le mois de
septembre on les a reportées au nom
d'une pseudo négociations
supplémentaires
vous arrivez avec un calendrier
complètement dingue
à quelques jours des vacances de noël
revenons pas là dessus comment ça va se
passer au parlement
est-ce qu'on va avoir un accord
complètement bouclé est ce que le
parlement va être respectée vous avez
dit je vous ai entendu dire il y aura
des amendements
oui jusqu'où est-ce que le gouvernement
va venir nous dire c'est comme ça et pas
autrement et vous acceptez le système
moi je vous dis cette retraite cette
réforme des retraites
elle a été tellement contredite par le
chef de l'état par le premier ministre
aura le commissaire douala lors du grand
père un coup c'était oui un coup c'est
hainaut le chef de l'état lui-même avait
dit il y aura pas d'âge qui vaut mois de
septembre
et puis en décembre ont annoncé sur leur
venant bien sûr et fort bien réussie
comment il a dit je de nom c'était à
biarritz pendant l'interview croisée
dans les 17
non mais je vous en fais qu'en asie
intervent pas non mais attendez avec
l'arrêt des contrevérités ne seraient
pas des preuves et rip
il avait dit je veux rien à côté de la
pivot soit étudié la question des durées
de cotisation a pas d'accord mais donc à
côté on suit vos d'orly la great eagle
hp dans le cadre d'une négociation mais
la question vaut julien oui ça c'est pas
racheté d'actions roger karoutchi soyez
pourrait s'il y aura assez de temps mais
malgré l on avait les carnavals il
répondait d'abord ces questions alors
oui mais mais il y aura le temps normal
pour un projet doit et que vous croyez
on n'est pas un parlement croupion
on n'est pas un groupe pro bio vous
devez vous dire mon problème en tant que
chef de groupe c'est plus de calmer les
avis divergent que mse elle a le secret
les xoni largement non mais parce que la
gestion du parlement aujourd'hui elle
est au mieux dans l'indifférence au pire
dans le mécénat trop vite non c'est pas
que ça va trouver les sujets concernant
très bien reçues mais n'ont pas de
réseau si senna jr sempe conclusive avec
le sénat il n'est pas monsieur leurs
salariés
heureusement et bien c'est très bien
c'est juillet même contribué à masquer
les faiblesses et bien c'est bien la
preuve mais parlement écolo ce
gouvernement c'est toi est ce que le
gouvernement est toujours respectueux
des droits du parlement à ce que le
gouvernement écoute toujours le
parlement pas vrai non mais écoutez
landa despatie tueur de plus en présent
arrêt avec deux malheureuses liste
d'amendements mais roger karoutchi je
voudrais vous poser une question est ce
que vous êtes pour ou contre la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
moi je ne suis jamais dire ni pour ni
contre avec ça vous a regagné for me je
suis content normandie aubin si c'était
vrai je serai dans le camembert mais
c'est raté
non moi je suis gouré ce qui me dit
qu'il ne croit pas à la fin des régimes
spéciaux
je n'y crois pas parce que en réalité et
vous et ça a été je suis favorable à
lembach a du mal à faire fermer les yeux
braqués les oreilles
non mais j ai regardé les cheminots
faire a demandé un uchi koné gagnent à
combien de réforme des retraites
avez vous été associés en 2010 et 60 à
62 ans il s'était jamais été que des
capitaux la halle rafistolage il faut
recommencer tous les cinq ans et bien
attendant de voir le succès de la mode
passée à autre chose une petite question
sur figaro live parce que les
téléspectateurs peuvent nous envoyer
leurs questions sur verlag
c'est claudius sur le site du figaro qui
dit ce projet de réforme a été écrit par
le medef
qu'est ce que vous répondez d'abord le
medef non c'est faux
bon ben voilà c'est faux c'est une
réaction des téléspectateurs et voilà
c'était c'est inexact
un an et demi par monsieur delevoye qui
vient de démissionner aujourd'hui et
alors voilà et alors je pense que leur
adore ça des juges l'auteur a ouai bah
alors c'est exactement le contraire que
de que des tous les syndicats depuis la
démission vient de marquer je ne suis
pas syndiqué le corps ben oui mais alors
comme ces syndicats par ailleurs sont
opposés à certains aspects de la réforme
s'ils rendent hommage à jean paul
delevoye à sa qualité du dialogue à sa
qualité d écoute c'est probablement que
il n'avait pas bien de dire à ses
parents toujours parce que mon action
allez on va parler de choses de
minimiser tout ce qui se passe depuis
deux ans et demi dans ce pays on va
parler d'autre chose on va parler d'une
autre loi qui en discussion en ce moment
à l'assemblée nationale la loi contre le
gaspillage à une question précise
oui parce que
madame bonnes poires sont la ministre
avait fait je crois le 10 août dernier
un tweet satisfaisant que la france
allait se débarrasser du plastique
jetable à terre junique voilà sauf que
l'âge interroge le président du groupe
un amendement est passé la veille le
lundi 9 décembre de la majorité qui
précisait que
c'était a de fait à n'arriverait pas
maintenant contrairement à ce qui est
dit sidy par exemple parlement européen
où le canada mais en 2040
donc pourquoi cette disposition qui a
été votée à la quasi-unanimité au
parlement non voilà pourquoi vous avez
le temps mais je veux juste se dire que
ce n'est pas simplement une lubie du
groupe la république
ça peut être une lubie des lobbyistes
auquel vous êtes à ses sommets cette
maladie car on attendait ces unanimité
du parlement répondait c'est cette
unanimité du parlement ça veut dire que
les lobbystes on te prie le cerveau de
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
j'en doute demain je vais maintenant
aller maintenant je vous réponds sur le
fond en 2040
il n'y a plus un plastique à usage
unique
ça paraît très loin mais vous imaginez
les transformations des appareils
industriels qu'il faut opérer dans tous
les domaines
parce que tous les métiers toutes les
professions toutes les productions
utilise du plastique déjà entendu ça
sauve des choses at non mélangés blast
où nous avoue n'a tout mélanger les
gilles et ona les retraites le
glyphosate et les plastiques une énorme
pierre lebeau majorie vous êtes est
totalement dans la nostalgie des
catastrophes majorité l'action du
glyphosate a traité en scène des
mannequins qui a réparé vous baissez le
respect dus par le brave et j'espère que
vous êtes là quand on vote à 4h30 les
j'étais là-bas le verglas alors donc
tout est donc arrêtée 80 de l'évier là
pour faire valoir que vous avez répond
j'y étais aussi mais sur les plastiques
il faut être raisonnable aucun français
ne peut penser qu'on peut changer
radicalement le mode de production du
jour au lendemain dunga la veine
pollution aussi fort voilà pas avec
cette intensité ce qui est important
ça n'est pas que ça soit 2040 ou 2035 ou
2030 ce qui est important c'est qu'on
commence tout de suite bien et c'est
exactement ce que précise roger
karoutchi à la parole parce que vous
avez été interpellé par les propos de
gérard collomb l'an dernier mise
l'intérieur qui avait mis en garde
contre la montée des communautarismes et
vous posez des questions sur notre
modèle français
non je ne pose pas de questions vous
voulez prouver extrêmement inquiet et je
c'est pas c'est probablement pas gilles
legendre qui peuvent répondre c'est
l'ensemble de l'état c'est l'ensemble de
l'état et le chef de l'état le chef de
l'état tient des propos comme sur
beaucoup de sujets qui sont extrêmement
forts et sur lesquelles on pourrait
presque se dire il a raison
vous n'avez pas mais je ne me gêne pas
quand il dit il faut lutter contre les
communautarismes jeudi la raison le seul
problème c'est que derrière ça ne suit
pas quand on interpelle le ministre de
l'intérieur diab mois les juristes me
laisse pas libre de mon action très bien
le résultat des courses c'est que on
voit bien aujourd'hui dans tout le pays
à la fois la montée des communautarismes
la montée de tous qui refuse l'état
refuse la france refuse le drapeau
refuse la nation exister on ne voit pas
de politique d'état qui fassent en sorte
que l'unité nationale doit respecter wes
quels grands textes sur le respect de
l'autorité de l'état et de l'unité de
voix lasse questions précises réponse à
leur guise
je m'inscris en faux totalement sur le
fait que nous n'ayons rien fait je
commence d'abord par reconnaître un
accord avec vous c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel dans notre pays nous devons
lutter contre les communautarismes
ça a commencé avant notre arrivée au
pouvoir et je dois rendre grâce et
hommage à un grand ami de luc carvounas
de l'époque qui s'appelle manuel valls
qui a le premier marqué le fait que ce
devait être un axe essentiel de la
politique
depuis nous ne cessons de renforcer ce
n'est pas des discours le que la lutte
contre le communautarisme
ce sont des actes et des lois nous avons
voté une loi qui permet de fermer les
lieux de culte quand ils sont dans la
dérive quand ils ne sont plus des lieux
d'islam
il faut les qu'il devienne mais nous
faisons non mais relever quand mon fils
vous savez très bon on expulse même v10
mammifères
on expulse offert non les écoles
coraniques fermer le nom vous dit qu'on
en a fermé 22 récemment mais a nommé
attendait oui mais à ben oui ou non nous
enfermons régulièrement et nous avons
doté le ministre de l'intérieur des
moyens qui lui permet de le faire en
toute légalité la fau est ce qu'il faut
aller plus loin
oui oui certainement mais attendez la
lutte contre le communautarisme c'est
aussi des outils bien nous avons très
fortement augmenté les outils qui
permettaient de lutter contre ça il faut
maintenant les mettre en oeuvre
on est en train de le faire et s'il faut
se doter de nouveaux textes nous le
ferons mais je ne crois pas que ce que
vous avez dit s'opposer à l'intérieur
est exact il a les outils pour le faire
et il le fait à gilles legendre une
toute dernière question de l'uqar
rimouski une question particulière à
vous poser c'est parce qu'ils me
demandent l'occasion d'en parler un
petit peu avant l'émission et j'en
profite ce débat il ya quelques jours
une grande chaîne publique relatait the
on peut le dire france 2 relatait des
agissements extrêmement grave dans un
club de natation de clamart sur les
agissements d'un entraîneur pour des
actes d'abus sexuels sur des mineurs de
moins de 15 ans il a été mis en examen
en 2017 et les plaignants les parents
demandent ont sollicité la ministre des
sports qui a eu récemment des propos
assez fort que soi sur les banderoles
homophobes les terrains de foot où que
ce soit la semaine dernière sur la
pédophilie dans le sport et les
plaignants que je représente un petit
peu ce soir aimerait avoir l'écoutent de
la ministre des sports qui n'a pas été
le cas aujourd'hui
souhaitons écoute d'autant plus qu'elle
est elle-même licenciés de ce club de
sport de natation de clamart elle en
vient
et donc nous aimerions est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à venir avec moi parce que
l'on sollicite la mini sur la base des
dossiers et qu'elle puisse diligenter
une enquête administrative sur les
dirigeants du club n'ont pas sur
l'entraîneur qui est dans une procédure
désormais judiciaire alors je suis sûr
qu'il n'ya aucune allusion malicieuse de
votre part au fait que madame marie
sénat où est était inversé ou soient
licenciés dans ce club et le fait que ne
veuille pas où je n'ai pas encore reçu
les vos amis où les personnages une
personne parce que vous voulez dire que
vous présenter aucune malice monde en
pot jakov fak
donc ça je pense que c'est important de
le dire parce que je connais très bien
roxana s'il ya quelque chose auquel elle
est attachée à laquelle est attachée
avec la dernière énergie
c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout pour
extirper ce poison mais qui est agite
malheureusement pas seulement le monde
du sport mais aussi le monde du sport
vous en partie à un ministre vous aller
la solliciter la mêlée mais relayé ce
n'est évidemment je vais le relayer mais
je ne pense pas que luc carvounas ait
besoin de moi pour s'adresser à roxana
maracineanu je ne crois pas je ne le
crois pas un club
alors oui je connais bien côté je veux
parler de ce sujet avec gravité parce
que moi ça me bouleverse
mais quand j'entends ça comme vous comme
roger karoutchi comme toute personne ici
c'est un fléau
c'est un poison que nous voyons que nous
avons vu éclore au cours des dernières
années dans différents milieux
l'église catholique le milieu du sport
le milieu du travail
c'est un faux le lutter et l'extirper
avec la dernière énergie
il ya une enquête judiciaire je pense
que ça ça peut justifier une certaine
retenue
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse faire
une enquête administrative virale
helmand une enquête judiciaire
mais en face il s'agit de saisir et
sensibiliser roxana je vous propose que
mardi demain nous allions ensemble à
voir au banc lors de la question au
gouvernement et que nous lui en parlions
arthaud les deux voilà c'est clair et
net
merci luc carvounas merci roger
karoutchi d'être venu sur le plateau
d'auditions publiques
on va cueillir maintenant il fera vous a
beaucoup écouté yves thréard
[Musique]
yves thréard du figaro françois rivard
france et qui a beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
écouté et qui a beaucoup de choses à
vous dire bonsoir gilles legendre
bonsoir et frère
alors vous avez une qualité c'est que la
langue est toujours souriant même quand
la l'heure est grave pour que les tracts
l'heure est grave la lsm chose qui m'a
étonné quand vous avez dit à vos
interlocuteurs je crois que c'était à
lui car menace vous mélangez les gilet
jaune avec l'histoire dernière élevé de
pouvoir les mélanger oui mais attendez
vous avez oublié une chose c'est qu'il
ya une opposition à la politique qui est
conduite par le président de la
république et la majorité qui est la
même une opposition virulente qu'on
retrouve dans la rue qu'on retrouve
certes de façon chaotique avec le gilet
jaune un peu plus organisés où l'avait
reconnu avec les syndicats vous n'avez
pas peur que ça se termine mal tout ça
il ya une hypothèse où les choses
peuvent se terminer très mal dans notre
pays entre art et je le dis avec une
extrême gravité
si nous cessions de transformer le pays
et de trouver les unes après les autres
les solutions à des problèmes que les
français traîne depuis des décennies ça
c'est le vrai scénario catastrophe pour
l'éviter depuis deux ans et demi nous
prenons c'est vrai des risques
politiques et je suis prêt à reconnaître
que parfois dans l'exécution que nous
dit que nous des mesures que nous
prenons nous souffrons d'un déficit
d'explication de communication tout ça
est exact mais vous ne pouvez pas nous
retirer une chose c'est le courage
politique qui nous amène à d'abord tenir
les engagements que nous avons pris
pendant la campagne et transformé
transformer transformer le pays qu'est
ce que vous faites si lundi prochain 23
décembre
mardi 24 décembre les trains sont
bloqués les syndicats ne veulent
absolument pas entendre ce que vous leur
dites vous ne voulez pas reculer et que
les parisiens les provinciaux ne peuvent
pas se déplacer pour aller voir leur
famille et que
les français vous en tiennent rigueur
j'ai dit tout à l'heure au début de
l'émission que nous faisions tout
absolument tout pour que ce scénario
n'est pas lui mais si c'est ce que vous
disait yves si vous pensez que même si
cette situation qu'encore une fois nous
allons tout faire pour éviter se
produisait puisse nous amener à renoncer
à ce projet ce serait nier tout ce qu'il
contient de positif pour les français
arrêtez vos cousins juppé comme vous
connaissez très bien l'histoire
politique de notre pays frère vous savez
que la situation n'a rien à voir pour
une raison très précise alain juppé
avait décidé de supprimer les régimes
spéciaux sans que le sujet n'ait jamais
été mis au débat public et notamment pas
dans la campagne présidentielle de 84
nous ça fait trois ans et demi que les
français savent que nous voulons faire
ça et sauf le haut niveau et si
souhaitons tour et surtout ils savent
pourquoi nous voulons le faire c'est à
dire être beaucoup plus juste beaucoup
plus solidaire et m
non mais attendez il créa et je vous dis
selon à vaulruz mémoire et de naturalité
à traiter vos fêtes vous vous connaissez
tous mais je peux le comprendre
une erreur fatale et que les français
eux ne commettent pas je vous faites
tous comme si le régime actuel de
retraites était un régime qui
fonctionnait correctement géré dit
qu'ils étaient financières sécurisées
passé les pieds étaient jérusalem alors
que les français le savent et quand il
juge le régime actuel vous actions d'une
sévérité extrême poser une question qui
va vous permettre d'être plus clair tout
à l'heure vous avez essayé à
l'impossible nul n'est tenu
frêche qui lâche déquilibre qui n'est
pas l'âge pivot c'est le même c'est la
même concept qu'on à moi qui l'avais
combatif d'un gérard guittat il ya du
grain à moudre comme disait monsieur
bergeron que j'ai bien connu il ya du
skill nous rajeunit pas du grain à
moudre
mais alors vous dit une chose
extraordinaire et qu'il veut ni
obligatoire enfin obligatoire il faut le
garder c'est un fait mais vous dit prêt
à négocier sur le malus
nice alors ça veut dire qu'on enlève le
bonus on en veut il reste là et c'est
pas tout ou rien j'ai dit dans la même
dans le même propos qu' on ne rentrait
pas dans une négociation en se mettant
dans une position binaire où on garde
tout on supprime tôt une négociation
c'est par définition des compromis le
point qui pour nous ne peut pas être un
compromis parce que c'est la protection
ultime que nous offrons aux français
d'aujourd'hui de demain et d'après
demain c'est que le régime de retraite
que nous allons mettre en place soit
sécuriser financièrement ça c'est une
règle d'or de même que c'est une règle
d'or que nous nous sommes engagés à
respecter qui est le fait que la valeur
du point qui était une grande crainte
des français ne baissera jamais ça c'est
des règles d'or le scénario qui permet
de respecter cet équilibre financier
il est sur la table nous devons de
discuter et il abritera une multitude de
sujets ça ne sera pas revalorisé dans la
comprenons pour arriver à un compromis
il faudrait aller on espère alors on va
quitter un peu les retraites on va
s'occuper des élections que les
élections à trois mois des élections
municipales vous êtes concerné au
premier chef
1 parce que n'est pas candidat certes je
veux et vous êtes savait mais à avons à
vous êtes c'était un piège à a peut-être
conseiller municipal il sort à paris au
code à ben évidemment à paris suivi des
nationalistes concernés qui s'évade
après bien sûr d'aller sur les livres de
besançon doubs sarah beeny sait pas
encore avec le taquiner yves frère qui
disait vous né sur un candidat
je dis que je fais je serai peut-être en
soutien sur une liste pour soutenir une
des listes d'un des affrètements
benjamin griveaux je le fais campagne
tous les week-ends pour lui le conseil
de paris probable voilà probablement pas
bon alors à paris il ya deux candidats y
en a un qui est officiel qui s'appelle
monsieur griveaux l'autre qu'est
monsieur villani vous les connaissez
bien tous les deux se sont l'un et
l'autre vos députés
enfin vous êtes collègues ou air fra 6 à
9 35 ans est très relative
est-ce que vous pouvez pas tranché vous
n'avez pas une quelque chose à dire là à
mai à dire j'ai beaucoup de choses à
dire les cas évoqués le les deux ans
qu'ils ont arrêtés
je leur dis est depuis longtemps et je
ne suis pas le seul alors dire beaucoup
de choses
vous savez ça les regarde moi j'ai fait
mon choix c'est celui qu'a fait de mon
mouvement
c'est le choix de benjamin griveaux et
je m'en suis expliqué très clairement à
cédric villani qui est un fait rare et
qui a parfaitement suivi l'avis est
encore a encore sa place à la république
en marche et dans votre groupe
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous pouvez pas le
l'ex pire mais jamais de la vie
pourquoi je les dis très clairement au
mois de septembre que ce n'était pas
comme ça que nous voulions fonctionner
bien dans notre mouvement va voir et
dans notre groupe nous verrons francis
letellier
pour l'instant je fais campagne pour un
candidat rumeur qui a des mariés bien
voulu quand même vous en débarrasser des
baraques vient certainement de milani ne
m'en débarrasser comme en bas a demandé
aux parties de l'exclure du parti non je
les dis exactement l'inversé vos
confrères en septembre il était même le
premier à le dire et tout le monde va
dire ça faut dire que les autres étaient
pas d'accord avec vous non ils l'ont dit
après moi je les dis en premier
voilà corps voilà c'est tout mais
attendez les choses sont très simples
benjamin griveaux fait une excellente
campagne une très belle campagne et je
suis derrière lui et je le soutiens et
encore hier l'impliquerait pas par les
sondages et encore il hier et encore
hier je tracte est pour lui avec les
marcheurs de ma circonscription et j'ai
bien l'intention de continuer comme si
quelque chose est assez intéressant
monsieur legendre c'est que aux
municipales on voit qu'il ya énormément
même vous de députés qui sont tentés par
les l'expérience du terrain des
municipales c'est pas ça me fait dire
pour certains d'entre eux qui sont déçus
par leur mandat du thé non alors guère
pour beaucoup d'entre eux ce sont des
nouveaux dieux vous dire parlement qu'il
y aura très peu de députés candidats à
la malle au premier poste au poste de
magistrat demain si pâle de mer dans mon
groupe
très peu très très bien vous voulez
combien revient sur 300 on va voir les
investitures sont pas encore terminées
mais c'est une grosse dizaine une grosse
quinzaine
non non non du tout et puis et l'appétit
et puis et puis non mais après les
investitures sont presque terminés où
elles vont l'être c'est donc créé une
vision assez précise des choses qu
ensuite des députés est en vie d'être
conseiller municipal dans une ville de
leurs circonscriptions où dans un
arrondissement
mais c'est une très bonne nouvelle ça ne
les empêchera nullement d'exercer leur
mandat parce que le travail demandé de
début de conseil municipal n'a rien à
voir avec celui de député ou celui de
mer et en même temps ça corrigera un
reproche que je la pense vous avez déjà
pu proférer au moins une fois contre
nous à savoir que nous étions des boues
injectées des réalités le gardien
reproche trop d'argent et fraude et je
m'empresse de leur ep de lilia précision
7e 6e ou 5e pour vous je n'ai pas décidé
j'habite le cinquième à saisir mes
indications vous aviez raison de poser
des questions merci yves c'est l'aspect
de votre audition
merci d'être venus surtout n'oubliez pas
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
figaro live ainsi que sur les comptes
twitter de public sénat lcp assemblée
nationale
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
toutes les équipes qui m'aident à
préparer cette édition toutes les
semaines
dès l'année prochaine à partir du lundi
13 janvier 19h noter le rendez vous
merci et à bientôt
[Musique]